there was a video around i don't know
where they were but jeff bezos has got a
new thing and he was did see that video
yeah he was somebody there leo pulled up
she was all up in these girls she was
like this look at him smiling
killing tea she was capturing me yeah
man the richest man in the world and you
still can't hold your girl slightly
stupid i'm mad but i looked i literally
looked at that and had so many
interesting thoughts i can't say my
thoughts are interesting but so many
thoughts about it just in terms of
literally you can be rich as [ __ ] but
you're never going to be you're just
never going to be leonardo dicaprio and
his thing's bad as well
she's a milfie bad
who leo sting or jeff's team oh jeff
stinks milfie bad yeah i think
leo won't go for her though she's too
old she's way too well he only does he
likes younger fat he does 25
literally the most famous actor of all
time
if i want to bang 22 year olds i'm
banging 22
what are you gonna tell me
what cat what can you possibly tell me
wow what's a guy but yeah his ting was
down
look at him up at him
her chin was on his chest
i couldn't believe it jeff didn't even
get fixed
what did he do his role what could he do
fam
it made me realize that
because i was going to talk about i was
going to bring this up today like
it doesn't matter who or where you're at
it's just like
sometimes
you're just never going to be the alpha
in this situation it doesn't matter if
you're the richest guy in the world
you're never going to be a leonardo
dicaprio yeah and liam caprio is never
going to be jeff bezos
if he actually spin it he's never going
to be jefferson's he's never
fun but he's leonardo dicaprio there's
going to be yes there's leonardo
dicaprio and sometimes your [ __ ] is
going to drool over the end of the cave
and then there's going to be a time
where the tables are turned we could be
in monaco
and leo could bring his ting
on a little leo yacht and his team could
look up and see a big boy see jeff bezos
is yeah and now leo's thing's drawing
and he's like [ __ ] and jess looks down
it's like you're never going to be in
jeff bezos
and then elon musk rocks up
in a spaceship
elon musk works out and just says you're
never going to be neither of you are
never going to be me
in this electric yacht
it's never going to happen hovering
across the water yeah i literally
realized no matter who you are you're
never going to always be the alpha like
obviously jeff brought his ting to the
function she was gas of leonardo
dicaprio okay cool you can understand
why she's gaslight because leonardo
dicaprio is a famous good-looking actor
but if we're going to talk famous
good-looking actors the internet
dicaprio is never going to be aquaman
bro
he's never going to be jason
leonardo capper is never going to be
chasing my mother so just like leo could
bring a ting to the function and see a
young jason mamoa he ain't got leo money
but he's paid
he's paid more than enough he's rich and
he's handsome as [ __ ] stacked as well
yeah he's jacked yeah leo's gonna lose
his yacht
he uses yeah and his marbles he's gonna
lose his chat and his marbles and jason
mama's never gonna be the rock he's
never gonna be dwayne
jason is never going to be dwayne
johnson bro there's always going to be
levels to this you're always going to
lose your yet to someone and then
there's going to be people in there in
between
like you get to dwayne
but then dwayne introduces his yacht to
kevin hart who's just too funny too
funny and just too calm and cool just
cool and just quick
and dwayne's trying his best to keep up
but he's just fumbling
and kevin's got him on his toes roasting
him back and then doing just lost his
yeah
to kevin to kevin's small heart
bro it come back around what goes where
it comes about that's the circle it is
the circle of life like
kevin's wife must be around dwayne i
think [ __ ] that's a man
[ __ ] you know that's a man
but then dwayne's thing's probably
around kevin in a different scenario
killing get killed
killing on her knees giggling
losing her [ __ ] brown
and dwayne's looking look at daddy what
the [ __ ] are you laughing at like that
why are you laughing so much get your
[ __ ] together get your [ __ ] together you
don't laugh like this at all in here
you don't laugh like this like just like
that
why are you drawing for the inhaler i
didn't even know you had asthma
stop that
sometimes you literally have to accept
that
you you need to be
comfortable with who you are as a person
yeah yeah as long as you compare
yourself to other brothers
because jeff bezos could have crumbled
at home that night
seen videos around the internet of your
your yacht
buckling over leonardo dicaprio she
can't she can't deny that or take that
away she she knew what she felt when she
saw her fam you know what i mean she
knew what she felt was there was the man
that came behind him was slipping in
puddles
and and and leo has been around this
whole his life he knew what it was as
well he knew it wasn't he paid his dues
and went dipped dipped he did the
respectful thing he did the respectful
thing
i don't think i could have been that
respectful the richest man in the world
yeah is hungering oh they licked my lips
you would have seen a red dot on your
head bro you seen a [ __ ] red dot
he would have seen snipers at you fun